Speaker 1: Nikki Haley. Fine. She's not going to
tell you anything she disagrees with Trump on.
She's not going to draw any policy distinction.
She's only going to talk about identity. But what
about Tim Scott? Tim Scott is a Republican senator
from South Carolina. Tim Scott was also given the
opportunity by Sean HANNITY to draw a distinction
between himself and Trump when it comes to policy.
Tim Scott has not yet announced that he's running,
but the rumors are that he may well be doing that.
He didn't do it either. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: What are the differences in terms of
policy positions that, for example,
you may have with President Trump?
Speaker 4: Probably not very many at all. I'm so
thankful that we have President Trump in office.
Frankly, the policies that we were able to pass
from 2017 to 2020 were monumental. And I think.
Speaker 1: Any criticisms of the guy you might
run against, since you'll have to justify why
someone would vote for you over Trump. No,
his policies were great. Really? I mean,
it's very beautiful, beautiful presidency. HANNITY
asked Tim Scott a second time. Any just anything
you want to mention here, Tim? Might we then.
Speaker 3: Find ourselves in a position where,
you know, maybe we'll have six, seven,
eight, maybe ten, maybe 20 Republican
candidates on a stage that mostly agree on what
the governing philosophy and ideology should be
for the country, What works for the country.
Speaker 1: That's what we're going to have.
Speaker 3: Then where are the differences?
What would the differences be, do you think?
Speaker 4: Yes, a great question, John. I
would simply say this. What I'm learning
on my Faith in America tour.
Speaker 1: Is, yes, in order
to decide whether to run for president,
I guess he's learning during a Faith in
America tour. Oh, my goodness.
Speaker 4: Tell my story. As an
African-American who was born into poverty.
Speaker 1: He's doing the identity politics
thing to, oh, my God, these people, they know
identity politics. The two people who are or might
be running against Trump talk only about their
identity when asked about policy differences.
Speaker 4: Within a single parent household. The
strength of my community, my Chick-Fil-A mentor,
who happened to be a white guy, a Citadel graduate
from in South Carolina. He taught me that you,
no matter where you're born, you can rise
beyond your circumstances if you're willing to
persevere because you're inspired by the American
story. Leaning into that helped changed my life,
bringing people together, black folks and white
folks, not because of the color of our skin,
but because we have one single focus.
Speaker 1: We believe you might be
noticing there are no policy distinctions here.
Speaker 4: The goodness of America. I want to
share with people why we should be proud of who
we are. And at the same time, debunk the lies.
Speaker 1: All right. We're going to stop. This
is looking like the identity politics primary of
2024 on the Republican side. Let's imagine Tim
Scott gets in next. Okay. We will have Trump,
Nikki Haley and Tim Scott. Any policy differences
at all that any of you want to cite? Anything that
Trump did during his presidency that was
bad that you would have done differently?
Now? I don't know. But if you want a younger
minority woman, you can go with Nikki Haley.
It's Trump's policies with a younger minority
woman. There's Haley. If you want the slightly
older than Nikki Haley, but still younger than
Trump and black version of Trump, then you've
got Tim Scott that you can vote for. This is
unbelievable. And it is another one of these
examples of how the right loves to claim the left
is all about canceling and to forget suppressing
free speech. Actually, it seems like it's the
right that that is. Oh, the left is all about,
you know, regulating businesses and telling them
what they can do. Oh, it's actually the right
who wants to tell Twitter and all these other
companies what to do. We I could go down the very,
very long, long list. The left is about
restricting people's freedoms. And it's the
right that wants to determine what people can
do in bedrooms, for example. And in this case,
it's the right that loves to say the left
is constantly doing identity politics,
identity politics, identity politics. They
have to. And soon we'll have three candidates
who seem only willing to challenge the former
president's candidacy on the basis of identity,
On the basis of identity. Tim Scott being asked,
Give us some policy differences. It sounds like
we're going to have a bunch of people on stage
who all agree. Well, listen, you know, as I
go around the country as a as a black man, what
this is now what the Republican Party has become,
identity politics. It is madness. But you know
what? If their voters don't care about policy,
maybe this is the smart thing. Just have them pick
based on identity. Do you want the Indian-American
female version of Trump or do you want the
black American male version of Trump? What?
What is it you want? Because on policy, they're
not talking about it. And voters, quite frankly,
don't seem to care. Wild and wacky times. I'll
have these clips for you on my YouTube channel.
Find it at YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. Make sure you're subscribed,
folks. We're trying to push towards 2 million
subscribers and also be aware of The David Pakman
Show now available in Spanish for our Spanish
speakers. David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.